for those of you still with us we have a
tale of kindness told through an unusual
lens that of a police officers body
camera Don Dahler has a story everyone's
first birthday is important but this one
was really special it started a little
earlier in the evening to Gwinnett
County police officers spotted a woman
on the street body cam footage captured
sergeant Nick boney and officer Jimmy
Wilson's conversation with the unnamed
woman that's when the sergeant had an
idea when they reached home this
actually happened back in January their
supervisors didn't know about it until a
routine audit of body cam footage turned
it up I don't think it has anything to
do in general with being a police
officer I think I think a lot of people
do that every day it just doesn't get
seen the little girl will likely have
many more happy birthdays with many more
gifts but for her mother this single act
of kindness just might be the best Don
Dahler CBS News New York
I mean little things go wrong way that
is community policing exactly